[Music]
foreign
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
wow
uh
so brothers and sisters hope you guys
are well shallow welcome back i found
this video
found it very interesting and i just
want to show you a little reminder with
you guys inshallah
um and to be honest i'm doing these
videos lately because it's more easier
than just putting the camera out and the
audio and that
simple short videos inshallah and it
does the job you guys can hear my voice
anyways
um now what i love about khabib
a lot of people may love him because of
um you know him being a strong guy mma
fighter you know as muslim men or men in
general you know
you know we want to be like him you know
in the context of you know
he's strong and we think strength is
putting your opponents down
down and you know having a physical
strong body
or people are scared of you you know
this is not really the case because we
know if the hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
where he said strong is not the man who
can wrestle another man down but strong
is the man who can control his
uh self in a situation of anger
now one thing i love about habib is that
his
love for his deen his adap his character
towards his parents
and this is something that we're missing
how many of us can come and say that we
are obedient to our parents how many of
us can say that how many of us can say
you know what that the fact that you
know subhan allah if your mom
or your dad is afraid to ask you
something or they're asking you in a
specific tone because they're afraid of
your
attitude that is actually disobedience
it's actually just being because you
have caused them to
fear asking you certain things and that
is something we should be ashamed of
and khabib said in one of his videos i'm
not saying this is true or not but he
said my success
is based on my obedience to my parents
yeah and i believe that success
can be in other things obviously hot mma
thing and punching and that that's
that's a different story but now what i
wanted to mention to you guys brothers
and sisters
was a hadith because you can see how
khabib is a world star millions of
followers
and he's done so much things for people
you know
those that we know and god knows the
stuff that we don't know mashallah he's
somebody
that is a role model in the context of
his adapt his character the way he
carries himself his obedience to his
parents
and in this video like we saw his salah
in this hadith
it was narrated by abu hurairah that the
prophet saw allah said
the first thing among the deeds for
which the people will be brought to
account on the day of resurrection will
be their salah their prayer our lord
will say to his angels
although he knows best look at my slaves
prayer is it complete or lacking
if it is complete it will be recorded as
complete but if it is lacking he will
say look
and see whether my slave did any
voluntary prayers
if he had done volunteer prayers he will
say complete obligatory prayers of my
slave from his voluntary prayers
then the rest of his deeds will be
examined in this in a similar manner
now brothers and sisters how many of us
subhanallah imagine living our lives
five years ten years yes okay look we
have our ups and downs sometimes
and we live our life years on end and
not a single salah
not a single salah problem says this is
something we really need to question
ourselves can you imagine living
in allah's earth and with all the
blessings you have
but you find it so hard to praise allah
five minutes
you dedicate your time to everything
when it comes to the gym
when it comes to stuff like that you
know when to eat what to eat how to look
be it
uh you know this is this what the
brothers you know my sister go gym
you know what to eat when to sleep when
to train what body part to train
you've put everything on a routine when
it comes to let's say maybe the sisters
you know
they know everything about you know be
like the fashion or clothing or the
makeup or
do the dedication that you spend on it
and these things when you die
they're going to leave you your body's
going to be washed they're going to
leave you your body is going to decay
and subhanallah we do not give that
effort if we gave just
10 of the effort that we give to other
materials things
to our salah to our deen life will be so
different our relationship with allah
will be so different
in surah yah allah subhanahu wa
says about the wicked one who will be
asked
what has landed you in hell they will
reply
we were not of those who prayed nor did
we feed the poor
we used to indulge in falsehood along
with others
and deny the day of judgment until the
inevitable came to us
so the pleas of intercessors will be of
no benefit to them
so the idol worships they were
worshiping
now what is the matter with them that
they are turning away from the reminder
as if they were spooked zebras
fleeing from a lion in fact each one of
them wishes to be given a personal
letter from allah to
all to read but in fact they do not fear
the hereafter now brothers and sisters
when your readings you can say hold on a
second okay i don't pray masala but you
know i do
i do believe in the hereafter um i do
feed the poor
um i do uh you know um do other stuff
and righteous deeds
the question that needs to be asked is
the following brahman sisters how is it
that these these people this pagans
these people who didn't these mushriks
they didn't do salah because they didn't
believe in the hero therefore there's no
hereafter
how as a muslim you believe in the
hereafter you believe you're going to be
questioned
and yet alone you still do not pray
brothers and sisters i'm not going to
make you long all i'm just saying is
even if it's one salah a day
that is the rights of allah and wallahi
brothers and sisters
if you don't do that and you're going to
lose you might dedicate your time to
everything
i know some people subhanallah they miss
their salah because they they're doing
work or business or they're indulging
something and they are subhan allah
thinking that oh no i can't pray because
you know i'm working
or et cetera and i need to you know
there's a customer come in or this that
whatever it may be subhan allah allah is
the one who's control of your risk
you missing your salah don't think
you've added any uh
amount to your risk your risk is written
all you've done is committed the major
sin
and you've um missed salah and on top of
that you think that the extra 100 pounds
or two hundred pounds
let's say ten thousand pounds you're
going to earn was going to not come your
way
brothers and sisters khabib may allah
bless him inshallah and keep him from
is i find him admirable when i see him
praying salah in the gym or wherever he
is
he puts everything aside and praise
allah this
is what makes khabib strong when i look
at him and his strength i see his
strength in his religion in his deen
in his obedience to his lord that is a
strong
person that i see his wrestling his
boxing this that
i'll be honest with him it means nothing
it means nothing if you can be the most
strongest person on this planet
if you are not obedient to your creator
you are the weakest person i don't care
how big your muscles are i don't care
who you can knock out
brothers and sisters hope this reminds
the benefit to you guys inshaallah
and may allah bless you guys inshallah
please start praying salah
if you do want daily reminders you can
follow me on instagram which i'll give
reminders about salah inshallah
until
and keep steadfast to our religion take
care